Okay, let's start. Welcome, everyone.
Thank you for joining us so early in the morning.
If we can start with a thank you.
Okay. So this presentation, just to give you the stage,
will focus on the interaction between cancer cell and the
microenvironment, and this interaction at the local level are very important.
These will allow the tumor to grow and to evolve, and of course, also to
metastasize. But during metastasis, cancer cell will have to adapt to
each of the very different
organ that will metastasize. And what we will
particularly pay attention here is actually the systemic
interaction, rather than the local one, that the tumor will
establish with the rest of the body,
which will, in some way, facilitate the adaptation
of the tumor
at the metastatic site. So this is very complicated image, but it's
just to show you how different are the different metastatic niches
between the different organ. And in
this session, we will mainly look at adaptation mechanism between bone and
brain. And of course, we will look at the systemic changes which will
facilitate this adaptation, and also reflect on the fact that those changes
change the physiology of the organism as a whole.
So before further ado, I'm going to start by introducing our first
speaker, which is
Yibin Kang from Princeton. Please come
to the stage. And, okay, and
I think your presentation will start soon.
Yeah.
Thank you very much.
Great.
Thank you, Ilaria, and thank you all for getting up early to
join this session.
So my topic will be about co-evolution of tumor and the stroma
microenvironment during the progression of cancer metastasis, the dynamic
evolution during different stages of metastasis, especially the
organ sites of bone.
So one of the interesting phenomena that clinicians and scientists
know about metastasis is that it's actually a very inefficient event.
In patients, you could be seeing millions of the tumor cell disseminated every
day, but only a tiny fraction of them eventually make metastasis.
In the mice, we also know that not all tumors are created equal.
The same cell line, you can select for variants that have high
propensity to metastasize to different organ sites, and those
constitute only a small fraction of those tumor as well.
So then the key question is if all tumor in the same patient or in the same
cell line harbor the same mutations in
oncogenes and tumor suppressors, what makes certain tumor cell
metastatic? So over the years,
the field have come to a realization that a lot of the
genes, the so-called metastasis genes, or I would prefer
to call them cancer fitness genes, are the ones that not
really play a key role in driving initial events of oncogenesis.
But those genes allow the tumor cell to
adapt to increasing level of stress during
early invasion, dissemination, survival in circulation,
and then seeding in distant organ and then eventual outgrowths.
In each step, the tumor cell are facing tremendous level of
stress from the immune attack, from oxidative stress, hypoxia, replicative
stress, nutrient shortage. They also have to
adapt to different metabolic needs as well.
So
how does metastatic tumor cell achieve that? There are two ways.
One is through gaining of those so-called cancer fitness genes,
often through epigenetic changes to elevate expression rather
than sequence mutations. And second is the
dependency of the microenvironment, the so-called niche, different niche during
progression and metastasis. And this is not a new idea.
Actually, more than 120 years ago, Stephen Paget already
proposed this so-called seed and soil hypothesis that beautifully
explained the idea even without a clear mechanistic insight.
So one of the phenomena that he noted in
his original publication back in 1889
is that he noticed
bone is among the most frequent organ sites that are affected in
patients with breast cancer. And he noted that this could
not be explained by just the blood flow pattern alone, and that's
why he come up with this idea of the so-called seed and soil interactions,
even though 100 years ago, there is no tool to try to figure out what
happened during metastatic progression in bone.
So
in bone metastasis, there are a series of questions that we
ask, and I will try to cover in my short 20-minute talk.
What make bone such a fertile soil?
What are the genes in driving bone metastasis in tumor cell?
What consists the bone metastatic niche?
And also the spatiotemporal events of seed and
soil interaction. How does the soil
support the seeds, and what does the seeds do to the soil?
Do they change them as well? And what are systemic complication of
such interaction, and how does interaction affect
the treatments response of metastatic cancer?
And they are often more resistant to all different kind of standard
treatments.
So if you look at a microscopic image of bone metastasis, this
is looking at human breast cancer metastasis to bone.
You see many different stromal cell involved.
So tumor cells are here. What you often see is lining the bone
surface are a large number of these large,
multinucleated cell. Those are not tumor cells.
These are osteoclast, and they break down the bone to
allow continued expansion, and also that breaking down bone release a
lot of bone growth factors to stimulate further
malignancy of the tumor. There are also other bone cell type like osteocytes and
osteoblasts. They are bone building cells, but they also participate in
pathogenesis of bone metastasis as well.
And then we also see a lot of cells in the hematopoietic
lineage.So the question then is, what do they
do in the pathogenesis of bone metastasis?
So in bone, this is a major hematopoietic organ, and we know that there are some
pre-existing niche in bone, including the so-called interstitial
niche, including osteoclasts, osteoblasts and
mesenchymal niche cell. There's also perivascular niche that
is very important to support the hematopoietic stem cell
function.
So one obvious guess we have is that maybe
the tumor cells just take advantage of this pre-existing niche for initial
seeding, but also continuous growth expansion.
Also bone, of course, contain a lot of hematopoietic niche cell and other
cell type as well,
like nerve,
adipocytes, fibroblasts. They all could participate
in bone metastasis. The question then is to figure out what are the
components of the bone metastasis niche, and what do they do to support the growth
of the metastatic soil.
So I'm going to show you some examples of how tumor cell at different stage of
metastasis take advantage of this existing niche.
So tumor cell can
initially home to the bone using chemokine
chemotaxis, similar to leukocyte trafficking.
So for example, tumor can express high level chemokine receptor CXCL4,
and then get attracted to
organ sites in bone that produce a high level of
chemokine CXCL12.
Also, some of the same adhesion molecule involving
leukocyte trafficking like E-selectin, which is also very important to support
hematopoietic stem cell function,
also are utilized for early seeding of bone metastasis.
As you can see in here, this is GFP-positive tumor cell.
In early micro metastasis, they are often attached very
close to the vasculature. And the reason is they are taking advantage of
the E-selectin that is highly expressed in the bone vasculature.
And what does E-selectin do? Of course, one obvious function is
adhesion, slow down the tumor, and facilitate extravasation.
But biologically, attachment to E-selectin also
induce a phenomenon called mesenchymal to epithelial transition, because
oftentimes when tumor disseminate from the primary tumor,
cytokines like TGF-beta induce EMT.
EMT also increase the stemness of cancer cell.
When they disseminate to distant organ, we often know that the tumor cell
often undergo the reverse process, mesenchymal to epithelial transition.
This is required for proliferation of tumor as secondary tumors.
But that conflict with the idea that EMT promote stemness, MET
reverse that. So by engaging E-selectin, this
induce a non-canonical MET to allow the tumor cell to gain the
epithelial phenotype. And at the same time, E-selectin engagement stimulate Wnt
signaling activity that allow the tumor cell to maintain stemness.
And you can see that indeed, in those bone metastasis in
area of high vasculature density, the tumor
cell have high Wnt signaling activity, as shown by this Wnt reporter.
And this allow the tumor cell to gain epithelial phenotype and at the same
time maintain high stemness for early seeding.
The problem is in the late stage of
metastasis, often it switch to a osteolytic
phenotype that actually Wnt signaling inhibited that.
So there need to be a switch of signaling state.
So at different stage of bone metastasis progression, other
stromal niche is utilized, especially the interstitial niche.
So Sean Zhang and others have shown that by engaging
osteoblast and
using this so-called heterotypic cadherin interaction between E-cadherin
tumor cell and N-cadherin in the osteoblast, this stimulate the
growth of early seeded tumors.
And also later on, once the tumor cells start to
engage the osteoclast, this could impart through the
osteoblast induce cytokines like RANKL, M-CSF.
The tumor cell also produce other factors like JAG1 that stimulate
osteoclast maturation. That leads to breakdown of bone
matrix, and release bone-derived growth factors
like TGF-beta. TGF-beta is abundantly stored in bone matrix in
an inactive form. And breakdown of the
bone matrix by osteoclast and protease activity of the tumor cell
release active TGF-beta. And we know this is happening because by
histology, you can see that in this bone metastasis section, you can
see that the tumor that are facing the bone matrix
have the most intense staining of phospho-Smad2.
That's the indication of active TGF-beta signaling.
So indeed, there's a positive feedback from the
soil to the seeds via
bone-derived TGF-beta growth factor.
And so TGF-beta stimulate the increased expression of
JAG1 in the tumor cell. JAG1 can
directly stimulate osteoclast maturation from its monocytic precursor,
and also stimulate production of
tumor promoter growth factor like IL-11 and CTGF from
osteoblast. So in this case, through engaging
TGF-beta, JAG1, Notch feedback loop, the tumor cell
can actively engage different soil components and respond to
soil-derived growth factors like TGF-beta.
What we also found is that JAG1 could also be
stimulated in high expressing in osteoblast, and that
in turn protect the tumor cell
from chemotherapy. So chemotherapy induce JAG1
expressing in osteoblast, and that protect tumor cell from
chemotherapy-induced cell death.
This makes the tumor bone metastasis resistant to
chemotherapy.
So that is the reason that we,
in collaboration with Amgen, developed this neutralizing antibody 15d11
that target both tumor-derived JAG1 and
osteoblast-derived JAG1 in response to chemotherapy.And the
benefit is obvious.
This is the mouse experiment looking at bone metastasis development by
bioluminescent imaging in large scale.
You can see without any treatment, the tumor grows exponentially in bone.
With single treatment of either chemotherapy or JAK1 neutralizing antibody,
there's a 10% decrease of bone metastasis development.
But a combined treatment leads to nearly 100% reduction of bone
metastasis. So in not only targeting
stroma interaction, not only
directly inhibit osteolytic bone metastasis growth, but also make the
tumor more sensitive to chemotherapy.
So as I mentioned, there's a switch from initial seeding
in the perivascular niche of the tumor with high Wnt activity,
possibly induced by E-selectin engagement, to later stage of
high TGF-beta active state,
possibly because of osteolytic release of TGF-beta
from the bone matrix.
So there's a switch of activity. So how does this switch happen?
So what we figure out is that in response to TGF-beta,
the tumor cell also upregulate a gene called DACH1, which
form a biomolecular condensate, or the so-called phase
separation. As you can see in here, this is a DACH1 tdTomato
in breast cancer cell line forming these condensates.
And this condensate essentially secreted
casein kinase 2, which is essential for supporting
Wnt signaling, and essentially suppress Wnt signaling
activity. So by virtue of increased TGF-beta release, forming
a condensate, and suppressing Wnt, the tumor cells switch from
a high Wnt initial seeding state to high
TGF-beta later osteolytic state.
So you can see the progression of different signaling states during different
stages of bone metastasis development.
So I already show you some of the preexisting niche, the
osteo niche and the perivascular niche, that was utilized
by tumor cell at different stages of metastatic progression.
There's still a big black hole in terms of what are the cell types, stromal
components, that could be engaged by tumor.
Tumor could create their own niche as well during the progression of
metastasis. And that previously was difficult to study
because we don't know what are the component of the stroma, and we are not able to
identify their functional importance.
And this start to change with the technology development.
One is with the single-cell sequencing technology, and second
is with the development of niche labeling technology, including the
technology developed by our chair, Larry Menanke,
several years ago,
using secreted mCherry. And she kindly shared this contract with us
to study bone metastasis.
So what we did in here is, we engineered a tumor cell
to express GFP, so they are green. They also express a
secreted form of mCherry that also have a lipid permeating peptide
that allow them to penetrate the membrane of the neighboring cell.
So the tumor will produce this secreted mCherry, diffuse to
short distance, and then taken up by the neighboring niche cell.
So this allow you to label a niche cell, and then you can sort and to do
single-cell sequencing. So you have to do this combination of technology to
specifically identify, especially very rare cells.
Because if you just isolate all the cell in bone marrow, do single-cell sequencing,
you will miss those rare cells because they're in small number.
So even if they change significantly in number, you're not going to catch
them. So this just to show you that in bone metastas, indeed, you have
this double positive tumor cell, and they secrete
mCherry that diffuse up to about 80 micrometer.
And it will be taken up by the neighboring niche cell and painting in red.
And then we can then sort them out as single positive, mCherry
positive
niche cell. The distal cell, they are far away from the
tumor, will not be labeled, so they'll be a negative cell as
control. And then we also have additional control from the same bone marrow
cell from normal healthy mice without bone metastasis.
Then we can do single-cell sequencing
to see what are the enrichment or depletion of certain stromal component.
They are very close to the bone metastatic niche.
And this is essentially a near complete catalog of the
niche component in bone metastasis.
So one of the interesting observation that all the adaptive immunity
cells, the B cell, T cell, DCs are depleted
in bone metastatic niche, essentially making the bone metastas immune code.
And this is consistent with the observation that bone metastasis are
often much more resistant to immunotherapy compared to primary tumors.
And this is maybe partially explain that.
We also see enrichment of certain cell types.
For example, basophil is enriched in the niche in red.
And more importantly, this particular population of macrophage
that we call macrophage C, as you can see in here, is highly enriched in the
niche,
but not in the distal or the less in the distal or the healthy
normal bone marrow. They exist, but much less number, in
total number. So
in fact, when bone metastas form, Mac C actually only increase
slightly in total number, but they change their location.
They become recruited on the niche.
And that's why you need both the niche labeling and single-cell sequencing to
identify this particular enrichment.
So we are curious about what is this
population, what is this particular Mac C population that make them
unique, and maybe they play a role in bone metastasis. So we need to isolate them.
And we noticed that they express three
cell surface markers in high level, VK1 and
CD163 adhesion molecules, and they're actually functionally
important not only as markers. And they also have chemokine receptor
CCR3. And this is actually the chemokine that allow the
chemotactic attraction of those Mac C
to the bone metastas, because tumor cell express CCL5 as a
ligand in high level.So we can use these three
markers to isolate the triple positive
bone marrow macrophages and compare them to
general macrophages in both the normal and the bone metastatic
bone marrow from the mice. And the top enriched
signature is consistently the so-called heme metabolism.
So when you look at the genes that are highly enriched,
they are genes involved in iron transport, like for
example, transferrin receptor, which is important for iron import,
and ferroportin, which is important for iron export, and mitoferrin,
which is important for transporting iron into the mitochondria for metabolism.
Ferritin for iron storage and so on.
But also genes involving heme metabolism, heme synthesis, genes
involving cell adhesion, including the two adhesion markers that I mentioned
earlier, CD163 and VCAM-1, highly expressed in those
MacC population. And then also transcription factors like
S**C that is highly expressed. And S**C rings a
bell because this is a transcription factor that specifically
expressed in a particular macrophage that is well known in
red blood cell generation, the so-called iron-enriched,
iron recycling macrophage or erythropoiesis island macrophage.
So what is EBI macrophage?
So in our hematopoietic system, the cell dies every 120 days, so
we have to replace the red blood cell very frequently every day.
And we need our heme to make the hemoglobin for new red blood cells.
The iron
mostly cannot come just from the diet alone.
That makes up only about 5% of the iron that we
need every day. Most of the iron comes from the recycling of dying red blood cells
by the macrophage, this so-called erythropoiesis island
macrophage. So those EBI macrophages are nursing
cells. They use those adhesion molecules to attach to
immature erytroblasts and facilitate not only the
iron transport, recycling iron to those maturing red blood
cells, but also facilitate the process of enucleation, kick out the
nuclei to allow the maturation of macrophage.
Without the EBI macrophage, the erytroblasts will remain
immature, and then we lose
mature red blood cells, and the mice will become anemic.
And that explains why when patients have bone metastasis, they
often become anemic. So
that's the hypothesis. When tumor metastasizes to bone, they
use chemokines to attract the EBI macrophage away from
the EBI erythropoiesis islands and deplete them for
red blood cell generation. And we can clearly see that.
This is the normal bone marrow.
The blue cells are the iron-enriched EBI
macrophage.
When the tumor forms in here in gray, they attract those EBI
macrophages to the bone metastasis and away from the EBIs.
And the consequence is the change of the maturation
trajectory. So erytroblasts go through six
stages of maturation. The first four stages still contain the nuclei.
The erythropoiesis island macrophage supply the iron and also
facilitate enucleation to become reticulocytes and
then mature erythrocytes. So if you count by flow
cytometry, the cells at different stages, you can see that the last two
stages,
the mice with bone metastasis are depleting of stage five and stage
six, and that's why they become anemic.
The first four stages, even though the total number didn't change, the
distribution pattern significantly changed.
So in a normal, healthy bone marrow, stages one to four have a very
typical one to two to four to eight ratio.
When the mice develop bone metastasis, they're stuck in phase four
because they don't have enough iron, and we know that because when they don't have
enough iron, they express high level of iron importers,
screening for iron in all those cells.
And they also cannot take out nuclei, so they're stuck in phase four.
We also know that indeed this is the case.
So in phase four, in a normal bone marrow, you can see that there is a small
population of enucleate stage four cell.
In bone metastasis, that population disappears.
They're stuck in this nucleated stage.
And part of the reason is that the genes in the
EBI macrophage that facilitate enucleation, including
Mk,
Xl, Dns2a, often, usually in the
EBI macrophage, they are expressed in high level.
But in those EBI macrophages in bone metastatic mice,
their level of expression reduced.
So the tumor also changes the property of the EBI macrophage,
not only recruit them away from EBI, but also reduce their ability
to facilitate enucleation. Similarly, if you look at
the number of the EBI number by flow cytometry, you can also see
that the EBI number decreased significantly.
And part of the reason is that EBI formation requires adhesion
molecules, including VCAM-1, CD163, and others.
These are two of the three markers.
And again, the EBI macrophage, compared to regular macrophage, have high level
of expression of those adhesion molecules.
But when they are in bone metastasis, those expressions reduce.
Again, soil is changed by the seeds,
and deplete their normal function.
So we then test, is this important for
supporting bone metastasis growth, not only causing anemia?
And so what we did is, taking advantage of this
MacC population express high level of transcription of S**C.
We use this S**C EGFP transgenic mice that
mark the EBI macrophage in green, and we can flow
cytometry sorting out. We co-culture with the tumor, and we show that indeed
they promote tumor growth in vitro.We can then also use GERA mice
to deplete those EBI macrophages because GERA mice
specifically target GFP positive cells.
And then if you use GERA mice to deplete EBI macrophage compared to
normal mice without the GERA T cell to deplete the
IMAC,
the bone metastasis in IMAC depleted mice grow much more
slower. So this shows that indeed those IMAC are very important to
support bone metastasis growth.
This is published, so you can check out the paper.
Not only this is important, when tumor
take advantage of iron supply from the IMAC and also in
combination with hypoxic condition, they also change the property.
They actually take up some of the property of the erythrost.
They have high level of beta globin expression, they have high heme expression, and
that make them survive better in a hypoxic bone
microenvironment. So you have IMAC involved in bone niche
formation. This cause anemia and at the same time it
gain the benefit to the tumor cell because they survive better in the hypoxic
condition. What's interesting is that in our spatial
single-cell sequencing study of the primary tumor, this is primary tumor, not
bone metastasis, we can see that surrounding the primary
tumor,
we already can see the enrichment of this triple positive IMACs.
As if they probably are attracted, maybe in circulation or from the bone
marrow, migrate there in primary tumor, and this already
give those initial primary tumor some survival advantage and start
to change the property. So that when they disseminate the bone marrow, they got
very ready to take advantage of this iron-rich population
microenvironment in the bone.
And this also shows that if you just look at a primary tumor, if the primary
tumor have high beta globin expression, this is one response to
high iron supply and hypoxia, they have high risk of
developing bone metastasis and not to other organ sites.
Also, for the single cell sequencing of the niche, we
saw, as I mentioned to you, the depletion of the adapted T cell.
Those T cells are also more exhausted, less cytotoxic.
And a recent experiment we did is that the same mouse
primary breast cancer that respond very well to
anti-PD-1, their bone metastasis do not respond to anti-PD-1 at
all. So we are now very interested in sort of figure out what does IMAC do and
other this component do to make the bone metastasis
immune cold and also don't respond to immunotherapy.
So I'm going to just wrap up here. Those questions I raised to you
earlier, sort of addressed by some of the studies we show, and this is
a continuously evolving field.
We showed that the bone is a fertile soil with not
only the pre-existing niche, but also tumor can create their own niche by
taking advantage of the particular stromal cell types.
The seeds also have the plasticity to take advantage of this niche,
including epithelial-mesenchymal plasticity and also different kind of so-called
mimicry.
The bone niche have several different components and also the bone-derived
factors also play a role in promoting metastasis.
And this niche seed and soil interaction not only drive the
metastatic progression, but also have systemic complications like anemia,
immunosuppression, and many other functions.
And this may explain why metastases are often resistant to therapy.
And by understanding that, maybe we can come up with approach to treat
metastases much more effectively.
So in the end, I want to thank people in my lab who did the work I
show you today, and happy to take your question. Thank you.
Thank you. That was a beautiful presentation.
We have microphones-
Oh.
-over there, yeah.
Hi, Yibin. Great talk and fantastic work.
I'm Yue Fan from Johns Hopkins. Actually, I have two question.
Firstly, you mentioned a three marker, right?
Whether it could be a
translational clinical biomarker to guide the treatment.
And the second, you mentioned the niche become the immune code.
So whether this relate to the remodeling of the
extracellular matrix protein? Thank you.
Yes. So the first question is the marker.
And so the marker VKAN1, CD163, and
CCR3 are the markers that we use to identify
IMAC. And actually, those are markers that exist in normal bone marrow as
well. So,
I think if you try to use those marker as a
indication of bone metastasis,
because as I mentioned, the IMAC actually doesn't increase dramatically in
number. They just change the location.
So I don't think you can use those marker to assess
the bone metastasis degree. But they could be
useful in the regards of-- I think what
we want to achieve is to block this recruitment of
IMAC away from EBI to the bone metastasis because we need them,
right? We need IMAC to support red blood cell formation.
We don't want to cause anemia in patients by just depleting them.
And so we can't really just eliminate IMAC, but we want to prevent them to
be recruited by the tumor cell. So how do you do that?
I think one of the potential is to try to target CCR3,
because that seems to be specifically used by MACC or IMAC to
be recruited to niche. So it potentially could have therapeutic
application. The second one is the microenvironment,
the matrix microenvironment. It's true that with
the involving the tumor disseminate to bone,
they could change the composition of the matrix surrounding them.
Because the tumor, of course, produce a raw protease, and they also
recruit different cell types. And that could
alter not only theDirectly, the tumor
deposit matrix, but also indirectly by changing the cells
surrounding them, change the composition of matrix.
I don't think this has been extensively studied systemic yet, but I think it's a
big open question.
Thank you.
Thank you for a great talk. Very interesting.
So do you think these mechanisms are specific to breast
cancer, or it can be generalized to other cancer types?
Yeah, good question. I think it's probably generalizable.
Actually, I didn't show, but you can look at our paper.
We did clinical studies of bone metastasis from
various solid tumors, breast,
prostate, melanoma, thyroid.
They have similar features. They have enrichment of IMAC.
The tumor cell have high heme activity.
They take out the iron, they express beta globin.
And so I think a lot of mechanism we study, like
E-selectin engagement, we also confirmed to be involved in
prostate cancer bone metastasis as well.
So I think this is a likely general mechanism, but maybe because the
cell origin is different for different cancer type, the degree of utilization
could vary a little bit between different cancer type.
Thank you.
Yeah. Next one.
Hi, David Lu, Dana-Farber.
Fantastic talk, and thank you for showing your data here.
My question is,
what is the
survival advantage, or what is the selective pressure?
I was struck by your finding in the primary, actually-
Right.
-for having the recruitment of EBI.
I think you talked about hypoxia, right?
Yeah.
In terms of in a hypoxic microenvironment.
Right.
And I guess in that setting, do you see evidence of greater oxidative
phosphorylation or-
Right.
-metabolic switches or specific requirements in those different settings?
Right. Survival pressure could be various.
One is, of course, the hypoxia, but also reactive oxygen species.
And iron actually could help in both ways.
Iron is one of the key elements that are important to alleviate,
reduce the risk of oxidative stress.
And also the metabolic, when the tumor in that condition
with high iron supply and hypoxia, they also actually increase the
oxidative phosphorylation metabolic activity as well.
So they also help them into the proliferation.
Iron is also very important for nucleotide synthesis.
So all those are advantageous for the tumor cell.
But I also want to mention that after benefiting from that, maybe this also
create a unique dependency. That the tumor require iron, and maybe make them
vulnerable for ferroptosis. Because they must have some mechanism to escape this
high iron-induced ferroptosis. But if we can tip the balance, they might be
particularly susceptible to ferroptosis.
This is something that we are testing in the lab.
Cara Valmejo from the Salk Institute. Beautiful work.
I have a question. So we have IMAC in the liver as well.
What do you think makes it more specific, this recruitment to happen in the bone?
Do you think it would take similar mechanism?
Good question. I'll keep it short and say it could play a role because Kupffer
cells also recycle iron. We now are doing some study in liver metastasis, something
that we're definitely looking into. Thank you.
My pleasure. This is our next speaker, Divi Yi from MD
Anderson.
I need to get my slide.
One again. Well, after Dr. Kang's really insightful talk, I'll
discuss how we disrupt the soil. Exploring
and targeting the pre-metastatic niche.
And here's a brief
outline of my 20 minutes talk. I'll
briefly introduce
the pre-metastatic niche,
and then
touch
on the zip code for the pre-metastatic
niche. And I also deep dive into the
unique architecture of the pre-metastatic
niche. And lastly, highlight the
clinical opportunities on detecting and
disrupting the pre-metastatic niche.
And talk about pre-metastatic niche.
Dr. Kang already touched on Dr. Paget's
seed and soil hypothesis. Basically,
back in 1889, he
described the distribution of the
secondary growth
in cancers of the breast. And he found
this non-random pattern of metastasis,
and asked, "What is it that
decides what organs still suffer
in a case of disseminated cancer?"
And based on his observation, he
proposed that the remote organ cannot be
altogether passive or indifferent
as regards to embolism. So this is the initial
seed and soil hypothesis. And
then in 2003, Dr. Fiddler from
my institution revisit this hypothesis,
clearly indicate that some tumor cellsMeaning the
seed grew preferentially in a microenvironment
of selected organs, the soil. And metastasis
resulted only when the appropriate seed was
implanted in its suitable soil, like this one.
So the suitable soil
now in scientific term is what we meant
metastasis niche, a nutritive and supportive
microenvironment for disseminating tumor cells to
survive, colonize, and grow in distant organ
sites. And now this
led us to this new concept of pre-metastatic
niche, which is beyond Dr. Page's
original hypothesis. I call it seed and soil 2.0.
What is a PMN? Well,
it's a receptive microenvironment in a distant organ
established, pay attention here, prior to the
arrival of cancer cells. Basically, primary tumors
can initiate a chronic systemic state,
gradually ripening distant organs to make them
become friendly, hospitable for disseminated
circulating tumor cells.
And the PMN
actually is not a static
landscape. It's a chronologically evolving
systemic state.
Represents the transition from a local
malignancy primary tumor to a system disease
metastasis to multiple organ sites.
And
talking about this chronologically evolving system state,
at least there are three
stages.
The early stage, we call the initiation of systemic
conditioning. Basically, right after
primary tumor formation,
and those tumor-secreted exosomes or factors
can get into a circulation to induce immune
suppression or remodeling extracellular matrix.
And the middle stage
more involve myeloid recruitment, and
it's a state of chronic inflammation to
license tumor cells for colonization.
And
one of the major change is recruitment of
myeloid-derived suppressor cells from bone
marrow.
The late stage involve in multiple
alterations,
and here are at least some of them: angiogenesis, immune
evasion, metabolic dysregulation,
neuroinvasion, which is relatively new
frontier
in term of PMN. And all these change can
favor disseminated tumor cells to outgrow
in the secondary organ site.
And here I use this cartoon to
reiterate the key steps. Basically, primary
tumors secrete exosomes of different factors
that enter the circulation, travel to different organ
sites. And once they are in these organ sites, they
can induce ECM remodeling or induce
immune suppression or angiogenesis to
establish the pre-metastatic niche to help
future arriving metastatic tumor cell to outgrow.
Well,
you can see
pre-metastatic niche in different organ sites are very different.
So
how tumors select the right environment for them to
future
metastasize to. So this brings to the concept,
the deep code of metastasis. And Dr.
David Lyden's team is really
a pioneer group, made a lot of important
discoveries. And
basically, the key message is that they found
tumor-secreted extracellular vehicles or
extracellular particles. They contain different
biomolecules on these
EVPs, and those biomolecules can
guide or determine where the tumor cell will
metastasize to. And they have
identified all these different
molecules guide tumor cell metastasis to all
these different organ sites. I'm not going to
discuss them one by one, but I do want to highlight
this one, CEACAM1/MIP.
What they found is that when tumor-secreted
extracellular vehicles express this
CEACAM1/MIP,
they will guide the tumor cell to metastasize to the
brain. And they also found that this
biomolecule can serve as a biomarker and
therapeutic targets
for brain metastasis.
And along that line, I like to deep dive
into the unique architecture of the
brain pre-metastatic niche.
Why I focus on this, well, I'm sure
you'll all agree that brain metastasis is really an
imposing clinical challenge, and the instance
is really high. Actually,
the instance is 10 times more than primary brain
tumor such as GBM, and this is
becauseMajor cancer types such as
melanoma, lung cancer, breast cancer, and several other cancer types
all have pretty high incidence of brain metastases.
What's really devastating is that once patients are
diagnosed with symptomatic brain metastases,
their median survival are counted by months
because we don't have many treatment choices
for brain metastases. So by
understanding the biology of brain metastases
niche, that can
guide us to develop effective
prevention and the treatment strategies
to tackle this new challenge.
And talking about the brain metastasis niche, it involves
different stages as well. First,
permeabilize the blood-brain barrier, which is a unique
structure in the brain. And Dr. Lydon's team has
reported
microRNA-181c
and others reported VEGF-A can mediate this
disruption of the tight junction of BBB
before tumor cell arrive or
extravasate into the brain parenchyma.
The second step involves the astrocyte
switch. Astrocyte is a unique cell type in the brain as well.
And it's known that stat 3
activation in astrocyte can convert
astrocyte from the well-known neural supporters
to metastatic niche architects.
And also,
brain metastatic tumor cells can prime astrocytes
to create an immunosuppressive niche to
escape from immune recognition.
The last step involving metabolic
preconditioning, or we call it metabolic symbiosis.
And the brain niche constantly
evolve to provide a nutrient-rich environment
for arriving metastatic tumor cells.
For example, provide GABA, lactate,
and that result in a very supportive
bioenergetic ecosystem for the future arriving
brain metastatic tumor seeds.
And now let's take a closer look at each phase.
Well,
when primary tumor enter circulation, travel
or home into the brain vessel,
this enlarge here,
they need to be able to attach
to the endothelial cell. We call it endothelia
address. And then after that,
so different molecular mechanism I mentioned earlier,
microRNA-181c, such as Dr. Lydon's
discovery, can allow
this tight junction to be disrupted,
and then tumor cells can extravasate get into the
brain parenchyma.
Now, once in the brain parenchyma,
let's move to the phase two, astrocyte switch.
And my postdoc, Dr.
Arseny Ugorlin, has found that
when brain metastatic tumor cell get into brain
parenchyma, it can
educate brain astrocytes. And these
astrocytes secrete this molecule called MLIN1,
transcriptionally upregulates CDK5.
This kinase through this downstream signaling
pathway, which I'm not go through the detail, the final
result is downregulation of MHC-1
and downregulation of antigen-presenting machinery.
And this allow brain metastatic tumor cells to
escape from T-cell recognition.
So
astrocyte-induced CDK5 accelerates
breast cancer brain metastases by suppressing
MHC-1 and antigen presentation to
evade immune recognition. And based on this
mechanic study, he uses
rosuvastatin, which effectively inhibits CDK5.
He was able to recover MHC-1 and antigen
presentation machinery to allow
T-cell recognition to kill. But now,
if without treatment,
brain metastatic tumor cell now can escape from immune recognition.
But for them to further outgrow, they need a nutrient.
And for that, it move to phase three, metabolic
priming.
And in these two side-by-side nature paper,
it's reported that key metabolites like GABA
and glutamate
can spark neuron and tumor interaction
fuel from the synapse, and that aid the
tumor growth. Basically,
they use this lung brain metastases model.
If lung cancer get into the brain, stay alone
without interaction, they cannot proliferate
effectively. But when they make friends with
neurons, they can proliferate really well
because neurons secrete GABA and glutamate
bind to the receptors on cancer cell and
induce electricity, and also
transcription of genes to help
synapse formation, also-upregulate
glutamate receptor to get nutrients.
And
based on this mechanism understanding,
now we can develop strategies
to detect and
target pre-metastatic niche. So for
early detection,
one common approach is liquid
biopsy, because it's minimally invasive.
By analyzing tumor-derived biomarkers in
biofluids before colonization of tumor
cells in the secondary organ site, we can get an
idea about pre-metastatic niche formation and
metastatic potential.
And
using this cartoon, we can simplify this idea.
We can take either blood for pre-metastatic, we also
take CSF from cancer patients, then
detect these niche signatures
shown below, including exosome, as I mentioned earlier,
a lot of work done by Dr. Leyden's lab.
And another approach is using
immunoPET. Basically, this takes advantage of
the high sensitivity of PET with
high specificity of monoclonal antibodies
that
recognize niche molecule to detect pre-metastatic
niche before using highly sensitive
MRI detection.
And you heard Dr.
Kang mention VCAM for bone
metastatic pre-metastatic niche.
And it is also a molecule in
brain and lung
pre-metastatic niche.
And because it's upregulated on the luminal surface
of endothelial cells in response to
tumor-derived inflammatory signals.
So these investigators
radio-labeled VCAM antibody and used
that for immunoPET.
And you can see before there's a
tumor formation at a very early stage using this
immunoPET, they can detect this pre-metastatic niche formation,
which you don't see using IgG control.
And basically later,
both groups develop metastasis at a similar level.
But with this, you can pre-detect.
And
this,
as I mentioned, became also highly
expressed in pre-metastatic niche of brain
metastasis. And targeting VCAM can
detect lesions
for pre-metastatic niche in the brain before
standard MRI can do.
We have those data. And
also based on this preclinical study,
a fully humanized anti-VCAM antibody
have been used for immunoPET and also
combined with this alpha particle therapy.
And this allows not only early
detection, but also
treatment targeting the
metastatic niche. We call it a soil
neutralization.
And along that line, I'd like to highlight
the
recent clinical and, of course, preclinical
progress in terms of disrupting the
pre-metastatic niche, the soil. And here just
highlights several candidate targets for brain
metastasis. And to save time, I'll
only mention the top one, REG here.
Well, REG expressed in cancer cells can bind to
ACE100 proteins that lead to tumor cell
proliferation and induce a
immunosuppressive niche
immune microenvironment. For example, M2-like macrophage.
And that facilitated metastatic
formation.
And based on
lot of preclinical studies,
REG inhibitor has been developed.
And in preclinical model, this
inhibitor was shown to reduce immunosuppressive
M2-like macrophage and also
inhibit MDSCs, meanwhile, enhance
CD8 T cell. So remodel
the niche component, allow
immune function. And
a very impressive preclinical study led to development
of a clinical trial,
ongoing trial. It's a Phase 1/2 study, assess
the safety of this drug, and also
combined with radiation to test therapeutic
efficacy in patients with brain metastasis.
We call it ADORATION trial. As of last month,
this is a new data showing the drug
is very safe and induce very
impressive early efficacy signal.
Partial response, almost 70% patients.
Complete response, 24% patients.
So this is a great example showing
that targetingPre-metastatic niche can
really help us effectively inhibit
metastasis, especially think about brain metastasis,
very hard to control.
And with that, I'll stop here, and here's a brief
summary of today's discussion. But
again, to save time, I'm not going to race through them.
And
the key take home message is that
we
are starting pre-metastatic niche with a major
clinical goal to shift treating
metastasis from only killing the
seed, the metastatic tumor cell, to also
delicensing the soil by
neutralizing this
pre-metastatic niche.
And with that, I'll stop here. Thank you for your
attention.
I guess we have two, three minutes.
Yeah, we have time for questions. Anybody wanted to start?
There are microphone here, there. Otherwise, I'm going to...
Okay. When people reach the microphone, can I just ask you quickly-
Sure
... one thing about-- I found that,
so that piece of data that you show that cancer cell in the brain
are educating the astrocyte.
Mm-hmm.
You have any idea of how that happened?
I mean, what does it involve? Every cancer cell, can they do it,
and how functionally different than the astrocyte?
It's an outstanding question. And after we publish work,
now we are using new lipstick system to
label tumor cell and see how tumor cell
interact with... Because astrocytes, there are multiple subtypes.
And so we identify the specific subtype of
astrocytes.
Okay.
And then it's an ongoing study. We are going
to use the omics technology
to compare those tumor-educated astrocytes
with normal astrocytes.
Of course. Thank you. That's perfect. Please.
Good morning. Great talk. I just had a question regarding the
S100 proteins. So you mentioned that the S100 proteins
have a role in the formation of the pre-metastatic niche.
Mm-hmm.
I have a question about the mechanism, how these protein contribute to the
formation of that PMN.
Well,
this work actually was done by a different group
publishing in the "Nature" paper.
And basically,
they reported not only this interaction
help tumor cell, meaning the seed, proliferate, but
mainly modulating recruit
the immunosuppressive macrophage
to the tumor microenvironment. So that's a
general mechanism actually
function both on the seed and the soil.
And more specific detailed signaling pathway,
please read their original publication.
All right. Thank you.
Thank you.
Here.
I don't see any.
Can I ask you a question from here?
Sure.
Seon Ra from Yonsei Cancer Center, Korea.
Thank you so much for the great talk.
I'm working with a gastric cancer.
It's a bit of different from brain or the
breast or the lung cancer, which is more of a
leptomeningeal seeding.
Mm-hmm.
My question is, like your brain pre-metastatic niche
theory is similarly working for the leptomeningeal
seeding, or it's only for the parenchymal lesion?
Well, in our
study, actually,
this although mainly contribute to
the
parenchymal-
Right
... metastasis, but also
pre-metastatic tumor cells secrete other factors induce
leptomeningeal metastasis as well.
And there are some overlapping mechanism, but there are also
separate
pathways involved in that.
Okay. Thank you.
A fascinating talk.
I was just wondering,
with respect to metastatic niche,
does different cancer type share similar mechanism, or
does the mechanism differ? For example, in brain pre-metastatic niche, does
lung cancer, brain metastasis also share the same for breast cancer?
That's a really
great question. So my short answer is
they are-- Different
pre-metastatic niche share some common features.
I mentioned this VCAM 1, Dr. Kang mentioned,
talk about its role in bone metastasis.
I was talking about brain metastasis.
It's also involved in lung
metastasis, and I won't be surprised involved in
liver metastasis as well. So that's a common mechanism, but also
different organ sites have their unique
mechanism
as well. So that's my general answer.
Thank you.
Okay.
One more question?
Thank you.
Thank you again for your talk.
Okay, so here's the time for the final talk.
And after all these introductions, I think I
don't need many.
So okay. I have no conflict. Okay. So basically, the message here is
that the local microenvironment is fundamental for tumor, but it
also-We also need to consider that it
has to be studied in the context of the entire organisms, because there is
an interaction between the body and the tumor, and vice versa.
And the pre-metastatic niche is this conditioning that happened before.
So as
we have been talking
this morning, is basically from the moment that tumor appear,
there are immediately, even before become metastatic, perturbation which affect the
whole body. We call it pre-metastatic niche or body
conditioning. An example of that has been given, but
conceptually, I want to make a small distinction here that,
as Diwa was suggesting and beautifully
describing, there are some of these effector, like the
exosome, which are very much deterministic in a sense that they can go
as far as influence the tropism of
metastasis when cancer cell has to metastasize by changing specific
tissue and increasing the chance of that tissue to become metastatic.
But other changes, and particularly the one that relate to
metabolism or inflammation, they're more global.
So they change the body in a more general way.
And they can, and they will,
influence metastasis, but they can also have impact for the
physiology of the body as a whole, and this is also important.
So we particularly focus our attention on neutrophil, which is one of these
global perturber, as you want to call it.
So we know there is a large body of literature that
tell us that many tumor, and breast cancer is one example,
are able to perturb and activate a
injury-like response in the bone marrow, and therefore activating
a
production of neutrophil, which is an
emergency production. So this is called emergency granulopoiesis.
It's controlled by very specific transcription factor and signal,
and it generate neutrophil which are more, and they're also very different.
And the fact that they're different is important because those neutrophil
will systemically spread in different organ, and in organ like liver and
lung, they will change different parameter of the organ.
And now I listed here three key parameter which will be changed in
the tissue. And what happen is that when cancer cell arrive, of course, a
pre-metastatic niche effect, there is an increased adaptation of
the cancer cell and a faster metastasis.
These metastasis will need to form a metastatic
niche. So this local environment which then will allow the growth.
And what I would like to point out is that those
subtle changes that happen already before cancer
cell arrive are already in the part of the tissue, which then
will be needed to construct the metastatic niche.
So we can call, let's say, we can see the pre-metastatic niche as an
anticipation of what will then be needed
to form the metastatic niche, which will actually be the
reason of this favoring of the initiation
process. And because we focus on neutrophil, and I told you that they're produced
in a high number and they're also different, we point the attention here
to neutrophil, and we did this study, trying to identify additional
function that neutrophil might have beyond the one that we already know.
So here you just see a
development of neutrophil from the bone marrow at the single cell level, from GMPs
all the way to mature. And in the context of cancer, as we know, because it's
been reported, these neutrophil are very different.
And if we sequence them, we can actually find them in this active state.
They're very
immuno-prime.
They're more ready to act no matter what the stimulus is, and they also have a lot
of metabolic changes. So Nicholas, which is in my lab, is
working on this project. He wanted to dive a bit deeper into this
metabolism and
ask the question, what are the neutrophil
secreting when they come from mice which are naive or
mice which harbor tumor? And we did an unbiased metabolomic,
and a lot of heat came up, so I'm going to cut the long story short and
only say what we focus our attention on, which is a change between
uridine and uracil. So neutrophil, only when they come from context of
tumor and produced in these emergency granulopoiesis, they can
uptake uridine in the media and release uracil.
And this actually can be done by an enzyme, which is called UPP1.
And in fact, neutrophil do have this enzyme, and they only express it when
they're produced by emergency granulopoiesis from the immature pool, as
you can see. Once they have it, they'll keep it.
So also mature neutrophil in circulation and around will have
UPP1, will be part of their priming in a sense.
And here, just show you because it's really a black and white situation.
It's not there when they're produced in steady state, and it appear when
neutrophil are produced in the context of tumor.
So in the mouse, physiologically, it happened the same thing, that in
the media, so we have in the plasma an increase of uracil, and this
can be cleared by depleting neutrophil for two weeks.
At this point, we also check in human.
We had an opportunity to look at plasma of very early breast cancer patient.
These are patient which are just at diagnosis.
They just went through a mammogram, and they got their biopsy, so
they are asymptomatic. Their tumor are very, very small, and these are before they
receive any treatment. And already at that very early stage, if we look
at neutrophil
in the circulation of this patient, we can see that they have more of this
UPP1 expression. And in their plasma, there is a
trend to have an increase in the uracil as well.
And I repeat, these are very early stage
of cancer.So it seems to happen also in patient,
and the question is, why is it needed, UBP1 for
neutrophil? So we
have this UBP1 knockout mice, and we gave them tumor,
and we discovered that actually for the emergency granulopoiesis, UBP1 is
dispensable. The neutrophil are still produced in high number, but
they're produced differently. So transcriptomically, they are very different.
And their transcription change already at the very early stage.
If we look at the pre-neo, which are the progenitor
of neutrophil, we can find that those, this is a RNA velocity
where we can see the amount, but also the trajectory of differentiation of this
cell. We find that this cell are, of course, more because they're more produced,
and they also differentiate very fast because it's a fast production.
And in the UBP1 knockout, that's exactly the problem.
So we have a lot of progenitor, but they don't differentiate
fast enough. There is a rate of differentiation which is reduced.
And if we look deeper into the dynamic of this RNA,
when you have a fast differentiation in cell, of course, the turnover of RNA
would be faster, and that's what we find normally.
There is a pool of RNA that remain more stable.
In the UBP1 knockout, the turnover of RNA is also fast, but what
is missing is this more stable pool of RNA.
So we're curious about it, and we ask what is enriching that pool.
And these are all factor which
are elongation factor initiator.
So that point really a potential difference in
translation activity, which we tested.
And indeed, we do find that the progenitor in the context of
emergency granulopoiesis, they have an increased translation, but this increased
translation doesn't happen in the UBP1 knockout, and this is continued also
later on in the immature pool. So this, of course, can
influence the rate of differentiation because normally, neutrophil need
to produce a lot of protein to differentiate at that speed of
production, and this doesn't happen in the context of in the UBP1
knockout, but the transcriptional landscape of the cell will still push them
through differentiation. So the results of that will be that
we have a high production of neutrophil anyway, but their profile is
now completely different. They're deficient in many of the feature that
characterize them.
And if we test their overall protumorigenic activity by using
UBP1 knockout
mice in
specifically neutrophil which harbor tumor, and we look at metastasis, we see that
overall these mice have less metastasis.
So clearly they're less protumorigenic.
But I told you that their overall phenotype is
changed, and indeed, so many things neutrophil can do
in the pre-metastatic site to favor metastasis.
So we thought about using these
mice or this UBP1 different neutrophils to
understand potentially additional function that we
don't know about neutrophil at the target site.
So we start to think about what they can do.
And one thing that we discover more
recently
in the metastatic environment, so within the metastasis at the
early stage, is an engagement with the available cell of the tissue,
so epithelial cell. And what we found is that these epithelial cell
rewire and acquire this stemness and regenerative potential.
And this in turn increase the stemness and the tumor
initiation activity of cancer cell.
So we actually add another feature here of the metastatic niche, which
is epithelial regeneration. However, is
epithelial regeneration, as I told you before, a pre-metastatic niche is supposed
to be an anticipation of the metastasis.
So is this happening also at the pre-metastatic stage in
some stage? So this is what we ask. So are perturbation within the
epithelial cell in the pre-metastatic niche there, and
are neutrophil involved?
So to ask that, we just did a single-cell analysis of the lung
of mice harboring tumor or mice harboring tumor without neutrophil.
And here we focus on the epithelial cell.
And I'm not going to show all the detail of that, but we focus unbiasedly
to the progenitor of this epithelial cell.
And we found that basically there are many pathway which are changed,
they have to do with stemness and plasticity, and those are
different in cancer and they're influenced by the presence of neutrophil.
So in principle, at the transcription level, we could say that there is a
perturbation
within the progenitor. But this, of course, will have to have a
validation functional. And to do that, we basically
did organoid. So we test the entire epithelial compartment of the
lung to form organoid. And this is
a tool that you can use because organoid will only be formed
by cell which have progenitor activity in the tissue.
So essentially the number of organoid we have in this culture will tell us
how many cell have this progenitor function active in this very
moment in the tissue.
So we can take that number as a measure.
And if we now check the entire epithelial cell
compartment in naive or mice harboring tumor, the one that we
see some perturbation, we also find that indeed those
tissue are able to initiate more organoid.
And if we deplete neutrophil, this is normalized.
So we can see they're functional. But as I was hinting before, these are
changes which will have an impact on metastasis.
But this is a change in regenerative state of the tissue, which will have
implication for the physiology of the tissue beyond
metastasis. So we start asking, is then the tissue
different? Would it respond differently to an insult, for example,
having this high regenerative activity?
So what we also did is to challenge the tissue with an insult
which will induce tissue damage, like a flu infection.And we
gave mice flu with or without tumor, and then we look nine
days after when the flu is cleared and the tissue basically
is being repaired. And then we quantify the amount of damage that there is
in this lung. And we found that actually when mice have this
higher regenerative state to start with, the level of damage that
we find after the flu is reduced.
So there is an increased resilience to the challenge.
And if we deplete the neutrophil after they are not needed for the flu
anymore, we can see that there is an
increase in tissue damage. So somehow, neutrophils are playing a role here.
But I told you also that this feature is something that doesn't
target specific
organs. So in this case, lung would be the metastatic site.
Neutrophil will go everywhere, and everywhere will have this characteristic.
So then we ask whether other organ, which are other metastatic site, like the
liver or organ which are actually not even metastatic site or unlikely to be,
like pancreas and intestine, have similar changes.
So we made organoid with all of those organ, and we found
that in all of them, there is an increase of organoid formation
efficiency, suggesting that this is a systemic change, where in distant
organ, in general, there is an higher level of regenerative activity.
And in the lung, I show you that this is dependent on neutrophil.
So we pick another organ which is a non-metastatic site, like the intestine,
and we depleted neutrophil there, and we saw that this increase in organoid
formation is now clear as well. So it's still dependent on neutrophil.
So staying with the intestine, we also wanted to know whether this increased
resilience was linked to this increased regenerative state.
And therefore, we also did here an injury model where
we gave the mice DSS, whether mice harbor or not tumor,
and then we look 11 days after treatment, so
during the repair phase. And here you can see all the different damage that we
quantify in the tissue to make a comparison in term of
disease severity, actually, the injury in the tissue, let's say,
at this stage.
So you can see it here that very similarly to the lung, mice that
harbor tumor, they experience less
damage, specifically in the more severe
score three and four. And if we deplete neutrophil after the
damage, so during the repair phase, we can
see that again, we can rescue that damage that is there
when mice don't harbor tumor. So again, also in this case, which
is a tissue which has nothing to do with metastasis, we
have an increased resilience to an insult.
This is to say that these changes which will have potential
implication for the metastasis, they have potential implication for any other
thing that can happen to a body which is now
profoundly different. So if we go back to metastasis, so
then we will look at the lung, and in this case,
now the neutrophil, instead of depleting them, we look at them with this different
phenotype that we know they have when they don't have UPP1, what they're
producing absence of UPP1. So now we have mice which harbor tumor,
but they don't have UPP1 in their neutrophil.
And we see that also similar to when they don't have tumor,
we don't have that increased regenerative activity that we can read with an
increased organoid formation.
But the question is, how is now that the neutrophil are
mediating somehow this activation in the progenitor of the
lung? So to ask this question, again, we did it initially
computationally. So we ask
if this signature, which is increasing in progenitor activity in the epithelial
cell, in a ligand receptor analysis, what are the
cell which are in the lung which can potentially
activate that program? And the answer to that was actually
platelet. But platelet and neutrophil do
have a relation together. Already in the circulation, they form
neutrophil to platelet cluster, and this is very important for the biology of
neutrophil. And of course, in the context of cancer, there are more neutrophil,
therefore there are more neutrophil-platelet cluster.
But how about in the lung? In the lung, we know that
the platelet will only be in the vasculature, and also the neutrophil
will reside in the pre-vascular space.
So if we want to know the presence in the tissue, we have to perfuse the lung
and remove all the platelet which are in the vasculature.
And if we do that in a normal lung, you see that there is only the interstitial
space that we can visualize. The white cell here will be the alveolar
two cells, so they're alveolar cell which contain the progenitor.
And we have very little amount of neutrophil or platelet.
But in presence of breast cancer, now everything changed.
Now we have a lot of neutrophil and a lot of platelet inside the tissue,
in the interstitial space. And there are this cluster which are being formed
where neutrophil and platelet are very much in proximity of this
alveolar cell.
Here is the
quantification of that, what I just said.
And if we deplete neutrophil, we are actually clearing the lung and the
interstitial place from the platelet as well.
So we can conclude that the neutrophil, through this clustering, they're
allowing
the platelet to
relocate from the circulation into the interstitial place and
close to the alveolar cell. And how about our
mice, which are deficient in UPP1, and therefore they have a different
phenotype? So this different phenotype also relate to their surface
molecule. So indeed, in the circulation, the neutrophil cluster
that they can form is already much less in the context of tumor, as you can see.
And in the tissue, the same is true.
So we have less cluster, we have less platelet, and we have less platelet
and neutrophil, which are close to the epithelial cell.So this really
points
at this unit here, which is alveolar cell interacting with neutrophil and
platelet as a potential driver of this activation.
And to test this, we did it ex vivo. So we generated ex vivo neutrophil and
platelet cluster, and then we put them together to
see whether they could enhance the organoid formation activity of the
naive epithelial cell from the lung.
And you can see that only when neutrophil are decorated with platelet, the
culture will have more organoid, indicating that
epithelial cell that normally wouldn't form organoid, they will be pushed to
do so, and therefore they will acquire progenitor function.
And actually, platelet are already enough because if we just add platelet to
the culture, we already have a lot of organoid.
And lastly, if we now have a tumor-bearing
mice and we deplete the platelet for a period of time, and
we look in whether
the alveolar cell have this activation, we find that this is
actually compromised. So we don't have this
progenitor activation anymore in the lung.
And the last thing that I will mention is that why would the cancer cell
care? Why would this be a parameter for the premetastatic niche?
While we have shown, as I told you before in a previous study, that the interaction
between epithelial cell and cancer cell is important.
And
if we now test the difference between the
experience that the cancer cell have when the epithelial cell are in
this active state or not, we can see that there is a difference.
Because if we co-culture the cancer cell with the epithelial cell and we ask
them to form tumoroid, this tumoroid formation will be boosted
when the epithelial cell are in this progenitor
active state, and it's compared to when they are at the steady
state, either because the mice have no tumor or because
the mice have tumor but the neutrophils don't have UPP1, and therefore this
activation is not there.
So to conclude, the take home message here that we
think that there is a systemic activation in the regenerative
state of this tissue. And the consequence of this is that this
become another parameter for the premetastatic niche because the alveolar cell in
this state can support better the tumor initiation activity of the cancer
cell. And I also show you that this, at least in the lung, is due to
the mislocalization of the platelet
from the circulation to the interstitial place and close to the
AT2,
which is mediated by the neutrophil interaction.
And lastly, I also told you that despite all the transcriptional
control that there is when we activate emergency
granulopoiesis, there is another level of control, which is metabolic, and
this is through this switch of UPP1.
And without this switch, the neutrophil will be produced anyway, but they won't
have the phenotype that they are supposed to have when they're produced in
this emergency granulopoiesis state.
And therefore, this bring us to the potential hypothesis that UPP1
inhibitor can actually be used as a potential
inhibitor for the prometastatic activity of
neutrophil.
And with this, I'm going to close and thank everyone in my lab, and
Nick, which I already thanked, that is driving this project,
you for the attention. And I also want to mention that we are in a
computational postdoc, so if any of you with just this expertise
interested in joining my lab, just talk to me. Thank you.
Question, please.
Hello.
Oh, sorry.
Yeah.
Kai Kessenbrock from UCI
in Irvine, and great talk. I really love the neutrophil
data. And I was wondering
at what stage
in-- So this was the PyMT mouse model where you-
Indeed.
- sequenced the neutrophils?
It was. Yeah.
And at what stage did you harvest the neutrophils, and
what was the source in this case of the neutrophils?
Bone marrow or blood or...
So
for the metabolomic we used... So it's a premetastatic
stage. The tumor,
we still don't have metastasis in the lung at that stage.
Right.
And
we basically took the neutrophil from different site, and we
look for changes which were consistent
in the different site.
Mm-hmm.
Because there were a lot of changes which were very much source dependent.
So neutrophil in the spleen or in the bone marrow
would actually produce a very different metabolism.
It's like a systemic change to the neutrophil population that-
Yes, because there are two level of regulation.
There is a level of regulation that happen at production, and then there is a level
of regulation that happen when the neutrophil enter a different tissue, and
then they also change.
Yeah.
So in this case, we really focus on everything that is changes everywhere.
So it would suggest a production change.
Yeah, that's very cool. And
with the
neutrophil specific UPP1 knockout-
Yeah.
- did you get a chance to sequence those neutrophils?
I'd be really curious to see what sort of the endogenous
changes are on the transcriptional level.
Yeah.
We have a transcriptional landscape of that,
which is why we saw this change in the
progenitor transcriptome,
andThe only thing that is
complicated is because UPP1 is not produced in the progenitor.
It starts to be produced later, and that's why it's
metabolic. I didn't show this data, but basically what happened, the uracil,
which is being produced, signal back to the progenitor
and impact their function, and this is how the things work.
So that's why it's a metabolic requirement, because it's really the level of uracil
production which influences the transcription rate and the differentiation rate
of neutrophil.
Very cool. Can I tag on one last question?
The images that you showed in the lung in the end-
Yeah
... really made me think there might be NET formation, neutrophil extracellular
trap formation. I don't know if you looked at that.
We haven't tested in this particular case, but we had looked
before.
Yeah.
And in this model, we didn't see that many.
Okay.
But we haven't looked in the UPP1 knockout, to be fair enough.
Yeah. All right. Thank you.
Yeah.
Who's going first? You were first. Ah, okay. Yeah, please.
Hi. So I'm Anant, and I'm from the University of Nebraska Medical Center.
My question is related to the disseminating tumor cells.
Have you seen this neutrophil-platelet interaction
helping the circulating tumor cells survive,
and have you checked?
We haven't checked that.
No.
Of course,
as the lab of Nicola Chieco has shown, the
neutrophil can form interaction with
the cancer cell, and I don't know whether platelets are involved.
And platelet themselves can also interact with cancer cells, so whether there is
the third option. I don't know.
But they're helping with the regenerative ability while-
Yeah
... right, making them help survive in the tumor.
Yeah.
Thank you.
Hi. Great talk.
I'm just curious, given all the kind of pre-metastatic changes and
conditioning that you and the other speakers showed,
if you had thoughts on what cautions you might have in terms of
interpreting results from preclinical
metastatic models where maybe there isn't a pre-metastatic component,
like
tail vein injections, cardiac injections, those types of things.
I'm just curious what your thoughts are there.
Yeah. This is a good question. Obviously,
there are different things you're testing, and
when there is the seeding, there will always be a primary tumor.
So in a context of seeding, the pre-metastatic niche will have
a very strong effect.
For the metastatic outgrowth itself, that might or might not
happen because it depends on the timing of the metastatic growth that occur.
Often, metastasis in patient will come after the
primary tumor has been removed,
and therefore, at that stage, it would be relevant then to ask the question how the
cancer cell can grow in a certain tissue, even if the primary tumor that imposed
those systemic changes are no longer there.
So it's really dependent on the
specific question we are asking when we choose the model of where to study it, I
guess,
if this answer your question.
Yes.
Thanks for the great talk. My name is Lucky from the University of Cambridge.
Yeah.
I noticed that you mentioned the formation of the clusters of the
neutrophils and the platelets are in the perivascular side.
Yeah.
Is that, I understand correctly?
If so, I was wondering, have you checked any T-cell infiltration of your
model in that sense?
Yeah. No, we haven't looked at the moment
at other inflammatory component.
It's something we are doing at the moment. Yes.
The cluster already form in the circulation, and then the idea is that they're
probably, neutrophil are probably piggybacking the platelet
as they intravasate into the tissue.
But I guess-
These could affect other inflammatory cell.
You're completely right, but we haven't yet.
Looked at it.
This is something we are doing at the moment. So I don't have an answer.
Cool. Thank you.
Ilaria.
Yeah.
What do you think are the platelets doing, and do you see
netosis in these clusters when they are in the tumor?
In the tissue, we didn't see any netosis when we
looked at.
Not at the level that is significantly appreciated.
If you will look in the liver, in the liver, you will find a lot of these
neutrophil which are undergoing lentosis.
In the lung, this happen a lot less, unless there is a
stimulation, an insult, or any other sort.
And what do you think the platelets are doing?
I think that the platelet are doing what they
normally do in the context of an injury, because in the context of an injury, there
will be exposure of platelet
to the epithelial component of a tissue, and they're known to support
the regenerative program. So the proliferation of the cell and the activation,
really, of the progenitor and regenerative activity.
And I think this shouldn't happen at steady state, which is probably
what? It's just a mislocalization of the
platelet from the circulation
to the tissue, and that proximity, that should happen only in a context
of an injury. And this is probably what rise the level of
regeneration. But this is something we are looking at now.
So we're trying to understand what they're really activating in.
TGF-beta is one of the thing they are doing, of course.
Yes.
Great talk. So I was wondering, this is a very naive question.
Can you come a bit closer? I don't really hear.
Can you hear me?
Yeah.
So,
have you considered that UPP1 may also
not be fully maladaptive?
It might be a very naive question, but I noticed that it was
also increased in all early
disease patients, regardless of outcomes, and it also
had some positive impacts in mediating
damage.
So I'm not sure I understood exactly your question.
So it's whether the level of UPP1 are change?
If you think that aside from
pre-metastatic niche contribution, it could also have
impacts which are not necessarily related to
pre-metastatic niche-
Yes
... cancer progression.
I totally believe that. I think the UPP1
relation to neutrophil, it's not specific to cancer even,
because we see that any
activation of emergency granulopoiesis, even the one that is induced by a
bacterial infection, for example, will have it.
So this is really about
what neutrophil look like when they're produced by emergency granulopoiesis,
which is a physiologic response to any insult.
So they need to be in a certain place to fight bacteria or to repair
injury. Even in colitis, they will be
activating that way. And UPP1 is needed for that phenotype.
And the same way that is needed in that context, is needed when
neutrophil acquire these changes in the context of tumor when they go through
this emergency granulopoiesis activation.
Thank you.
Yeah.
Okay. So if there are no further question, so
I'm going to close the... Unless anybody have another question also for
other speaker. If you are all good, then we're going to close the session here.
Thank everybody that participated, and thank you for coming.
Thank you.